johnathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers is probably one of the greatest
stories ever told I'm just gonna throw
it out there like to me it it is
incredible I feel like Hickman writes
the stories is like a book and then
turns it in as a script and then
somebody actually does the lettering and
then somebody you know is it's amazing
the way this gets done because it does
such a like it tells such an incredible
story now here's a funny thing this
whole idea again basically starts the
the whole play of the collapse of the
multiverse which is to say the end of
the Marvel Universe and then the
starting of all-new all-different marvel
so it goes into Secret Wars and all I
kind of get stuff but like I said it's
it's a huge epic so things just get
crazy and crazy and crazy as time goes
on but initially what we do is we pick
up in what Conda about a day before
really the the current events and so
what we end up doing is of course we
followed the technologically advanced
nature of what Conda now for those of
you guys who are new to Marvel Comics
who are new to like the Black Panther
mythos things like that whether it's
because you're getting into the movies
or what-have-you
what Conda is the most advanced city in
the world it's technologically advanced
on a multitude of different platforms
and the reason for this is because what
Conda is the only source of what kannan
vibranium remember there's two types
there's 80 metal vibranium which
basically breaks down metal on the
atomic level which is what you find in
the Antarctic or the Arctic or something
along those lines
what Condon vibranium can absorb sound
and also amplify magic and so because of
that it's actually the most sought-after
form of vibranium but because Wakanda is
the only place to get it they can charge
just insane rates for people to get
ahold of it not to mention that they
have like tons and tons of it now keep
in mind this comes after do more and so
really with the events of doom war
taking place Doctor Doom invading
Wakanda and of course you'll find that
video down in the description but Doctor
Doom invading Wakanda for the purpose of
basically trying to find a way to steal
all the vibranium and amplify his own
magical abilities for world domination
the response to this the result is that
Black Panther rendered all vibranium
across the world completely inert now
the reason why that matters is because
with vibranium being rendered useless
what Conda basically basically destroyed
his entire countries like social and
economic structure they had no means to
great money they were just a country out
there in Africa somewhere and so because
of this a black panther in addition to
the do more events had actually let his
sister Sheree take his place and she
became a new black panther and the
result was that T'Challa actually just
became somewhat of a figurehead but when
the time came for him to basically
retake his crown
it really wasn't there it was you
destroyed everything that made our
country what it is you're not gonna be
Black Panther again and so in this
instance because he's basically the
smartest person in his country his roles
been confined more to like an advisory
position and really more of like
teaching and instruction now because
Wakanda so advanced they've charted all
these aspects of the spaceways where
they're not really launching chips into
space but they've charted all these
different aspects of the spaceways their
knowledge of Science and Technology is
well beyond normal humans and that's
what this does it initially emphasizes
the idea that they're focusing on you
know expanding their own their own
knowledge and and so on and so forth but
what is up happening is that in the
midst of all this T'Challa is actually
sidetracked by the arrival of an earth
from another presumably another
dimension now this is where things start
to get kind of crazy and start to get
kind of hairy because we don't know
where this earth came from all we know
is that this earth is there and so the
question is where did it come from well
this comes with the arrival of a
character known as Black Swan now this
is when we start to get into like Thanos
his black order to a degree um really
Black Swan was never really part of the
black order per se in terms of like what
you think of Corvus glaive
evany ma Proxima midnight the whole idea
is that she actually joins it later on
but this sets the stage for all that
stuff happening now of course they're
actually speaking high Sumerian a
language that hasn't been spoken on
earth and you know years and years you
know decades thousands of years probably
not that knowledgeable about the
Sumerian language but the idea here is
that black panther is able to understand
her to a degree but of course once she
starts speaking English everything
becomes a whole lot simpler but this
woman Black Swan starts speaking
cryptically talking about destroying a
world different things like that and
before black panther can stop her not
only does hers do her soldiers kill some
of his some of the people from his own
tribe she ends up destroying the earth
now the death of some of these members
of Black Panthers community is a No
keep in mind when it comes to T'Challa
he guards his his wakandan his laconic
country jealously woe betide the poor
soul who comes into his country and
starts causing trouble because chances
are they won't make it out in one piece
the problem with this is under normal
circumstances he would have killed her
no questions asked she would have been
done it would have been one of those
things he would have killed her and
buried her in the mountains and that
would have been the end of Black Swan
but because of the fact that she comes
bearing you know this gift of
destruction for a whole nother world and
blows the planet to pieces he can't kill
her because the question is why is she
here and why in the world did this
planet get destroyed and so what do
chala ends up doing is the one thing he
never wanted to do and that's reform
deilluminati now a little bit of history
here
Marvel Comics has had a litany of events
over the course of their publication
history we've had the onslaught saga
we've had the Age of Apocalypse we've
had maximum-security where the earth was
turned into a prison planet run by Ron
and the accuser we've had all these
different events take place secret
invasion civil war so on and so forth
the biggest and probably were not really
the biggest but probably the most
important event to take place is the
kree-skrull war and the reason why is
because within the Marvel Universe the
Kree and the Skrulls are warring races
that have been battling one another for
millions and millions and millions of
years the creation of the Inhumans was a
byproduct of the Kree to create a race
that could basically serve as
infiltrators they could deal with
espionage and they could be soldiers the
cria band in the project before anything
actually came of the Inhumans and they
ended up just becoming a self-governing
Society but these groups have been
warring forever now the kree-skrull war
came dangerously close to impacting
earth and what ended up happening is
Iron Man Tony Stark came to the
realization that dr. strange that Reed
Richards of the Fantastic Four
blackbolt of the Inhumans that these
characters knew about the Crees World
War Professor X they knew about what was
going on and each of them had a piece of
the information that if brought together
would have allowed them to basically
stave off any and all efforts of the
Kree or the scrolls to impact earth and
so what Tony Stark did is he formed a
group called the Illuminati and the idea
is that because the Inhumans are so
isolated because Doctor Strange is
isolated because Reed Richards on the
Fantastic Four
usually off exploring space because
Professor X and the mutants are largely
isolated within West Chester or at least
they were at the time the result is that
they basically began coming together and
pooling their information so that if any
one major crisis took place the
Illuminati would be able to operate
behind the scenes now the other half of
this is that the Illuminati was very
hush-hush nobody was supposed to know
that they exist but another introduction
into the story is that Captain America
was part of the Illuminati and that was
never originally the case originally it
was basically everyone you see here
except Captain America so this is a new
bit of information and it's actually
pretty huge because he's going to be the
voice of reason here for the most part
now of course what this also does is it
comes from the fallout of Avengers vs.
x-men remember that story of course
you'll find that in the description as
well that story dealt with the with the
return of the Phoenix force it resulted
in Tony Stark trying to destroy the
Phoenix force it dispersed itself among
Emma Frost Colossus Colossus sister
Illyana Rasputin but the most important
part of this is Namor the Submariner
because the fact that Namor as part of
the Phoenix 5 had basically launched an
attack against Wakanda and obliterated
most of the city itself
this created a huge amount of animosity
between Black Panther and between Namor
the Submariner the issue with this is
that there was a little bit of trying to
figure out what was going on
Namor was not really himself and so
while Wakanda I'm sorry Walla
T'Challa wanted to hold him accountable
to a degree he couldn't at the same time
it was the rebuilding phase so any
desire he had for revenge had to be put
on hold while Wakanda was being rebuilt
because again the challahs first and
most important effort is put towards his
people and then everything else is
secondary and so because of this the
relationship between Black Panther and
T'Challa is tenuous at best and there's
a lot of hatred between the two of them
but with Reed Richards basically showing
up and speaking to speaking to Black
Swan what she ends up telling him are
these cryptic things about the wheel of
death and about where some being named
Rob oom along we don't really know who
he is we just know that apparently he's
the one that initiated this whole cycle
or at the very least he's overseeing the
entire thing so again this is very
mysterious this is very cryptic but what
happening and this is probably the most
important thing that Black Swan says is
that those individuals who try to stop
rebou Maillol the Great destroyer those
individuals who try to stand in the way
of this wheel of destruction ultimately
will end up losing themselves they will
come to a crossroads and they will have
to make a choice do they let a world
live or do they let a world die and
ultimately if they do if they choose to
live if they want to continue their
lives they're gonna have to kill a world
and what it does is it breaks them on
the emotional level because what this
means now is no longer are they
protectors instead they're killers
because when you destroy a world you're
destroying everybody on that world who
destroy billions and billions of people
and that's the choice that has to be
made here now of course Black Swan also
hits at the idea that she's done this
multiple times and she herself has lost
her way she's lost who it was that made
her who she is but that's the sacrifice
she makes in order to be a Black Swan so
again with Reed Richards basically
coming back to the to the Illuminati
with everything he's learned what we end
up finding out is this is basically a
domino effect somewhere along the line a
universe was destroyed we don't know how
and we don't know why but we know a
universe was destroyed now it works like
this let's say that I take like five
dominoes or say or you know ten dominoes
or twenty now knows however many let's
take out let's say I take dominoes and I
line them up next to each other and
let's say I pick the two middle dominoes
and I knock them both to different sides
they will just end up knocking over a
dominoes next to them and that's what's
happening right now
the destruction of this universe created
a cascading effect and like you pushing
you know walls on either side of you it
ends up just causing universes to start
bumping into each other now the point of
impact for these universes is earth if
both earths hit each other both
universes will be totally obliterated
if one earth is destroyed then the
universes will pass right through each
other and nothing will happen nobody
will be the wiser but that's why these
earths are popping up is because it is
basically the point of an incursion is
what it's called when this earth pops up
you have eight hours between the time
you first see it and the time it crashes
into you and
that's the choice that they're basically
being given here that's what they're
being told the survival of Earth the
survival of the main Marvel Universe
hinges on the Illuminati's willingness
to destroy a planet now of course this
also leads to Captain America
immediately popping up and saying nope
we are not going to destroy worlds that
is not gonna happen now
this is kind of a cool moment and this
is why Captain America is on the
Illuminati because he's the voice of
reason keep in mind Captain America is
not the smartest the smartest person in
the world he's not the sharpest tool in
the shed
what he is is emotional and reasonable
he's able to combine those two things
together to come to what would be the
most reasonable decision in a
circumstance on the other hand you've
got dr. strange you've got Reed Richards
you've got Black Panther you know you've
got Professor actually got these got
World really Professor X isn't here he's
dead he died in Avengers vs. x-men which
is why he's not there but you have these
characters who for the most part are
extremely intelligent and in a lot of
ways are disconnected from humanity and
so really Captain America is the voice
of the people he's the voice of the
people in this instance saying should we
kill a planet should we not kill a
planet and so in his mind the act the
answer to this is no not only that they
have an out and this is when we
basically begin learning that each
member of the Illuminati possesses an
infinity stone and the reason for this
is because of the fact that one is
designed to basically show that each
member is who they claim to be now of
course Doctor Strange has magic at his
disposal to basically prove that these
vim individuals are who they claim to be
but as we know from years past stories
like Infinity Gauntlet infinity war
infinity crusade all these different
things that the Infinity stones can
easily overpower dr. Strange's magic and
so because of this it's basically an
identity verification
it's them essentially showing that they
are who they claim to be now the other
half of this is that where the old
Captain America says no we are not going
to go around and kill planets at the end
of the day the other members of the
Illuminati behind Captain America's back
are like look it's nice that he has that
idea but if it comes down to it we will
kill a world
we will obliterate a planet to save our
own that's just the way it is either he
can be on board
where he can get the boot now this is
huge because remember when it comes to
Captain America as a character at least
before the whole secret Empire thing the
Captain America's word in a lot of ways
was law when superheroes came along and
they said okay like we're in this crazy
situation you know spider-man what do
you think that we should do well you
know I think we should do this Reed
Richards what do you think we should do
you know I think we should do this
Captain America what do you think I
think we're gonna do this done that's
the way it worked in Marvel Comics when
Captain America said we're doing
something it got done for the most part
I mean there were a few instances where
it wasn't necessarily the case but
that's the respect that superheroes in
the Marvel Universe have for Steve
Rogers and so what we end up doing is we
basically pick up with this aftermath of
sorts of Avengers vs. x-men because of
the fact that it created a rift because
Cyclops is largely considered to be
untrustworthy among the x-men team
because of the fact that again following
the events of schism and so on and so
forth we end up having a Hank McCoy who
takes up the role as being the guy that
basically runs the Xavier Institute or
at least to a degree you know it's kind
of the guy who's running the Xavier
Institute but what this means is that
he's actually the person who inherits a
piece of the will of Charles Xavier now
the funny thing about this is that
Xavier just basically showed gives him
an envelope where at least he's handed
an envelope created by Xavier that just
says remember and what this does is it
triggers a psychic memory now this is
pretty cool and it's actually pretty
ingenuitive when it comes to Charles
Xavier in Marvel Comics his role for the
most part was usually pretty
straightforward he was a guide or he was
a guide for the x-men he would train
them he would teach them he would tell
them that hey look the x-men are a team
design more of a humanitarian group as
opposed to like a group of soldiers or
like a war group or anything like that
but the idea is that for the most part
he would plant these subliminal messages
in people's minds but usually it was
done against villains or it was done to
control a situation we didn't really see
instances like this where a memory was
put in beasts mind for the purpose of
him basically just sort of you know
eventually realizing it when Charles
Xavier triggers it and so because of
this what he ends up you know being told
by this psychic memory is that because
Professor X was part of the Illuminati
and because each member of the
Illuminati possessed an infinity
Stone in order to verify their identity
and their allegiance to the group
Charles Xavier
hands his infinity stone over to Beast
who in turn is immediately contacted by
the by the Illuminati themselves now
remember one of the things that was
established and the Illuminati
miniseries is that where it was
previously believed that the Infinity
stones were just these items it just
kind of existed out there instead
they're actually inherently drawn to one
another the Infinity stones always want
to be brought together again and so
really it was more like this stone was
like a like a tracking device if
anything you know with the Illuminati in
possession of the other five stones and
then beast having his they immediately
knew where to go find it the immediately
knew where it was located out now of
course this brings Hank McCoy into the
situation with the question of is he
okay with what the Illuminati is looking
to do more so than that it's actually
pretty ingenious in the sense that some
devices have been constructed that will
basically activate when an incursion is
happening or when an incursion is about
to happen anywhere on the world so if
the Illuminati are off with their own
respective teams or they're off doing
their own thing and you know they're out
in space or something along those lines
and their palms start blinking red they
immediately know to head back to earth
now of course this all ends up being a
moot point anyway as the story
progresses just because of the fact that
things sort of end up hopping off but
the other funny thing about this is that
Reed Richards initially goes to Black
Swan with the idea of hey we have this
idea to basically destroy or to stop the
incursions from happening and when they
tell her their idea is to use the
Infinity Gauntlet black swans response
is that's not gonna work because like
other people have tried we know what the
Infinity stones are from her universe
she knows what they are and she's bendy
universes where people have tried to use
them and in every single instance the
Infinity Gauntlet always fails now the
biggest reason for this was actually
solidified in the story I think it was
JLA the jla/avengers crossover and it
was the idea that the Infinity Gauntlet
only works in its own universe and this
has been confirmed before but this was
really sort of Ashton stone it's just a
solidified thing if you are in the main
Marvel Universe the Infinity Gauntlet
only works in that universe if you're in
the ultimate universe the Infinity
Gauntlet only works
and that universe you can't take the
Infinity Gauntlet from one universe into
another and expect it to work it doesn't
happen and because of the fact that
these are universes crossing over and
crashing into one another ultimately it
proves to be unsuccessful not only that
it's one heck of a show because what
ends up happening is with the Infinity
Gauntlet being reformed the question
becomes who's the one who's gonna wield
it well again this taps into the whole
idea of the respect of Captain America
because where the watcher realizes the
Infinity Gauntlet been reformed Galactus
especially Thanos where they all realize
this gauntlets been reassembled
undoubtedly the only person that the
Illuminati beam worthy of wielding it is
Captain America and it is crazy because
he's so overwhelmed with power but
here's the difference Captain America's
will is completely unshakable his
resolve usually cannot be questioned the
only instance where I've ever seen
Captain America seemed to give up was
and wasn't like age of Ultron when the
Ultron when Ultron it basically just
conquered the earth and Captain America
didn't know what to do he was just like
I I have no plan like I don't know how
to respond there's nothing we can do all
we can do is wait it out and hope we
survive to see tomorrow it was the most
defeated thing that I've ever seen in
the history of Marvel but in this
instance Captain America's will is
basically unstoppable and so where other
members like Reed Richards for example
gothy Infinity Gauntlet and were
corrupted by it
Captain America immediately knows how to
control it and is immediately able to
dominate it now of course this is his
effort to basically push this in cursing
earth away and try to get it to move
away as far as he can send that universe
back the problem with this is that the
amount of energy this sure amount of
energy that it takes in order to pull
this off is more than the Infinity
Gauntlet can handle and the result is
that all the Infinity stones except for
the time stone shatter into pieces the
time stone actually just vanishes it
disappears but in the mind of the
Illuminati this is it there's no hope
here like there's no way they can pull
it off because remember in the Marvel
Universe the Infinity Gauntlet is the
most powerful artifact in existence he
who wields the Infinity Gauntlet
controls all things that there is and so
because of this if the Infinity Gauntlet
gets destroyed then there's no way for
them to win and so once they go
back and they begin trying to figure out
a next way to BAE you know what this
next step is everybody in the Illuminati
except for Captain America basically
began saying if we couldn't use the
Infinity Gauntlet to destroy these in
cursing earth so to push them away then
the only option we have is to blow these
planets up that's it Black Swan was
right when she said we're gonna have to
destroy worlds we're gonna have to
destroy each and every one of these in
cursing worlds and so in this moment
where Captain America basically says no
I cannot abide this I cannot side with
this you know we have to find another
way
ultimately what is up happening is
Doctor Strange under the direction of
Tony Stark
wipes the mind of Captain America
eliminating every and every little bit
of knowledge that he's ever had that he
was ever part of the Illuminati allowing
the Illuminati to go forward with the
purpose of destroying worlds with that
being said guys I love the story so much
and it only gets better
it only gets better what we wanna
clickbait title Captain America gets the
Infinity Gauntlet man like do this this
story is so good it is dude I love
Hickman's Avengers and they were
Avengers it's
fanboy yeah I love this story so much
it's just so good oh my god is so good
anyway guys if you are new here to come
as explained make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the rob4 if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you